Golf et al. System Model Introducing Quick Start a
I'm wolfram Core Application Engineer
3 Cars 4 Kinds This course is a hands-on tutorial to get you started with the system and the temple
First  Ignore how to do it
Next, let's develop a model of electric kettle by dragging and dropping classes from the built-in model Lovely. Finally, I
will introduce the ideal species to learn more deeply
.  See the seeds You will understand how to develop a model and simulate using Ra in this system
. When
you start Ra in the system for the first time, a welcome screen will be displayed.
Here is a modeling simulation car seat.  Includes a link to an introductory video of the introduction
tutorials and document center
industry-specific use cases and other ideal shows can also be held at the beginning Asobo Street
Hotel model is perfect for getting started  It's a place
Click the button Many examples of thoughtful tutorials will open Here
you can learn the concept of Ra's cheat in the system For example, how to make a text day model with a halo For
example, in the electric circuit example, the component base is also modeled.
Now you can learn how to build a marine model.
This tutorial includes step-by-step
instructions to see how to develop models for various stations.
Introduction All the models used in the tutorial are intros.
It is included in the daft Leeds Ample package and
is listed in the Class Browser. The Class Browser has four sections
, from top
to bottom, user classes
in libra.  Package can see the class
Let's open the system package and open the inverted
pendulum char  Let's select the motor as the
motor Nishio and parameters such as resistance will be displayed at the bottom of the screen.
Double-click on the component to see its design.  You can also
here is the resistor inductor electromotive force etc.
You can also select more components in this and investigate in detail Let's simulate this model
Press the Wai button
3 Easily return to the class class simulation  Use the Run button to
monitor the
simulation Open Simulation Center Creates xperia mate for the
model All workshop years of the model and here controller
gear motor defaults can be accessed from the Experiment Browser Open
Motor Controller Motor Components Open Voltage  Let's
plot You can see the change of the motor voltage and the maximum value and the minimum value in the plot window. It
is easy to change the appearance of the head with the Prod theme
. You can choose from various plot themes.
3d Because it is mechanical
, you can also animate the movement of the pendulum.
Click the animation
button to open the panimation window.
Click the play button to start the animation.
You can zoom in and out with the scroll wheel of the mouse.
You can also set it to steal the playback method, for example, you can set it
to play continuously or set the playback speed faster or slower. The
animation function will help you to better understand the behavior of the system.
Let me tell you what's useful.
Click on a component in the animation that is out of sync. For example,
click Publish to open this component in the Plot tab.
Click on the cylinder to see all the transitions.
It may be interesting.
So far
, we have learned how to simulate an existing model and investigate it in detail.
Next, let's create a new model by dragging and dropping. The
model we will create is an electric kettle model
.  Is a small counter system, but I hope the system modeler will understand the function of Marutada Weirdo
.
This model uses the components and regulators of both the electrical consular and thermal stations
The model or stun included in the system chest  It's in the Dard
Library and you
also need to create a new model before assembling
Click the New New Class icon on the toolbar and select the appropriate class Here is the
model Enter the model description
with the model name as the
electric kettle
Click the caliber button to create the model. Once the
model is created, an empty diagram view of that model will appear. The
model name electric kettle is displayed at the top.
This model is a user class input in the class browser.  Also listed in
Let's assemble the electrical circuit of the model
Electric Car Analog Basic Open and say, hold down the mouse button on the ground class
and drag it to the class theme g view and release the mouse button
About the register  You can also
change the orientation of the component and easily change it.
Right-click on the component and rotate right from the shape.
There is also a remy shortcut, and you can do the same by holding down the control key and pressing r
.
Use a voltage power supply for the input of the model
This class is in the source package inside the analog As you
can see here there are lamp voltage so tooth
voltage and various power supplies
here choose sine bondage
Next, open the itr package from the analog
and select the ideal closing switch.
This is the last thing you need for the electrical circuit, so let's connect the components together
. In the
system modeler, the components are the connection lines.  Connect using a tool
Move the mouse over the connector you want to connect to change the appearance of the cursor. Click here once and move the mouse over the other connector you want to connect and click.
Repeat this.  Complete the electrical circuit
Next, electric the thermal components and add them to the toro.
These classes are in the thermal library of the model or standard library
.
First open the thermal
and open the components in the heat transfer.
Heat capacity capacity to represent the water inside
I'll
add it to the component large blog layer as I did before.
This component looks better to be
renamed Component-click and select Rename and name it
Water
Water Component  And resistance, that is, I want to connect a heating element, but I
can't connect it as it is.
This is because the type of connector is different. Because Japan is in the electrical area and the
other is in the thermal area.
What if I want to connect?
First cancel this connection operation and select the resistor. The
screen stock has parameters new c and port, so
set this to true.
Now the resistor has a thermal port.  Added:
Invert the resistor and connect the water and the components of the resistor.
Model the heat loss. Here we assume that most of the heat run is due to radiation.
Represent using a
class Drag this class into an elliptical g view to reorient
and connect to water You
can use a fixed input temperature to model the room temperature
Use a heat source for this
Intake rather than Kelvin  I want to use a shell, select a package tomorrow,
and drag a fixed temper packing net.
Now
you need a regulator to control the electrical circuit.
Open the logic package from the block and
turn off the heating element. Find a class to use for one-off.
It seems that you can use a controller with a book for
this class.  Let's open the documentation and take a closer look at
this class. It contains
information about connectors and parameters and
also has key examples of classes.
Open an example of a control temperer and see how to use this class.
Like Mr. Penn in the Controller Day document
, I also have a list of general information and parameter meetings and other components used.
There is also a Daigoron Day at the top of the page.
This is my  Similar to the model Doki  You can find out more about this tumor by clicking on the name of the main example at the top of the
simulation center and returning to the model center.
This controller
seems to work with my model.
Reference to tell the controller the set temperature of the water.  You also need
a signal, you can use a certain level of signal source for that,
which is in the source package inside the block, then
connect the package to the controller and
finally connect the on / off controller to the idr closing switch and the
system is complete.
I need a realistic parameter value before doing the simulation. In Sweden where I live, the
voltage is 230 and the frequency is 50hz.
I also use this value for the model.
And the question is, let's say the intake is 21 degrees.
The
reference temperature is set to
99 degrees. Since we do not want the switch to turn on and off every time the water passes 99 degrees,
we have a wide range of controller settings.
Let's say we heat 5 l of water once. The corresponding heat capacity is 4180 joules
parakelbin. Set
the surface area of the settle to 0.15 square 15 sq
are and the resis
ance value is to some extent in my office.  Drop out of the same 16 points
All parameters can now be set
Video verify if this model is correct before simulation This
can be easily done by clicking the verify class button
Verify that the model is correct
Finally, the model is
simulated. When the inverted pendulum
was simulated, the simulation was created as soon as the class simulation execution button was pressed, but
this model has no experimental settings yet, so the
simulation is performed.  You will be asked to review these settings before running.
You can use the standard settings or change their values. As you
can see, there are many settings,
for example numerical tolerances, step size peaches in the
kettle.  10 seconds is not enough to heat the water, so
let's set this to 300 seconds
Click ok to build the model and run the simulation
New Prodwin  Variables made and plotted
here Select the temperature of the water You
can see that the temperature rises steadily at the beginning
293 It starts from Kelvin and reaches 370 brother TV after 20010 seconds
This is also about 250 seconds
I want to check the relationship between the temperature curve and the switch, so
let's add a subplot.
Right-click and click New Thumb Plot
and select the output value of the king controller in the plot tab.
You can see that the controller is sounding until the temperature reaches the target value, it is turned off,
and the font is reheated to the desired temperature.
This seems to be a little easier to understand when
enlarged.  Drag the part you want with the mouse
and release the button of the choice lance. The
upper plot corresponding to the selected part is also enlarged,
but what if the conditions are different if there is little water in the petre, for example
1 liter of water  Try 0.5 l instead of.
Change the heat in the variable tab of the experiment and
simulate the experiment again.
If there is little water in the picture, the heater will turn off more often than in the previous experiment.
You can also see that, as
expected, when the amount of water is low, Joes rises early on Wednesday.
Again, the controller keeps near the main hall target temperature.
What if you want to compare simulations under two conditions?
It is efficient to duplicate the experiment for
this, and it will open as if you had previously done a parameter tatami with a new spelling surface. As you
can see, the name of the water component is displayed in a second place.  This means that the value of the variable
has changed from that of the original model. When
you open to Hong Kong there is a small arrow next to the value of the parameter Click this
to reset the parameter to the original value New experiment  Simulate
and compare the two conditions Some variables are shown in blue This
means that the plot is also sung,
one of which is the water book so this is the other before  It is plotted in the experiment.
Click this variable name to see two of them in one plot window.  A curve is drawn.
It's easy to compare simulations under different conditions like this and see how they change
.
You can also compare on-off controllers as well.
We've seen how to build a model and simulate it Car
Robot Insulation Signaling pathways and
whatever you want to simulate is a model so the procedure is the same but of
course there is no end to what you need to
learn.  I'll talk about the 6 people and the center of the Hemp menu before.
Wow ah ah ah ah It's a hub that brings together
all the resources to help you learn more about modeling in system errors
.
For example, start with the Jetting Star section.  It's a
collection of 9 and real videos and tests. It covers a
variety of topics, from basic to advanced, and
also includes advice on different aspects of the modeling language library software.
There is a mechanical library and various urine documents and key examples in the blue section.
Learn how to use the more mediocre main system modeler in industrial use cases
.
Manabe Masu here in both manufacturing and life sciences.
There is a major example at the station
Learning about the model day as it is The idealism is in Kofu
but Delica is
the name of the modeling language used at the root of all the resonating classes Advanced users
use the gangbang modeling language  Create a new custom class in the store list If you want
to customize the class
or create a poisonous class,
it's a good idea to start by reading more about the language for
this reason for Stem modelers.  It also contains a complete version of the Delica language crystal stone
.
This is also a step-by-step book that explains all of the Delica language using
examples.  You can see that the details of the points and functions are also
explained. In
this bose, we introduced the basics of the system modeler.